thank you
[Music]
so all right so Texas Republicans
proposed the creation of a vigilante
group to hunt migrants at the border
that will have immunity from prosecution
that's some hardcore [__] Patrick
one more time is this some vigilantis
Republicans at the border proposed
creation of vigilance group to hunt
migrants at the border that will have
immunity from prosecution but is it
vigilante if it's government sanctioned
no that's not vigilance yeah government
sanctions is this a response from uh the
El Paso what the [__]
uh this isn't government sanctions this
is just Republican people wanting to do
this is it lawmakers in Texas
specifically
um
the bill House Bill 20 would allow Texas
Department of Public Safety to hunt
arrest and Deport undocumented migrants
the group would be comprised of law
enforcement officers and civilians under
the direction of a governor-selected
chief the members of the group would
also be extended immunity from Criminal
prosecution relating to their actions On
the Border they will be directed to
arrest detain and deter individuals
crossing the border illegally including
with the use of non-deadly force the
group will also apparently be authorized
to use Force to repel arrest and detain
known transnational cartel operatives in
the Border region this is what
vigilantees always do they want they say
that again they want Vigilantes to
arrest cartel operatives official border
patrol right they want it's a
combination of law enforcement officers
and civilians under the direction of the
government selected Chief they're
supposed to use non-deadly Force for
migrants that are trying to just cross
the border illegally yeah however
they're allowed to use Force to repel
arrest anti-chain known transnational
cartel operating okay so if the guy
appears to be a cartel guy you could use
Force but these Mexicans which I think
is just like here's clear like loopholes
yeah we're hooking you up why would you
want to go after a cartel guy as a
citizen exactly yeah there's also half
cops too would you want to do this yeah
dude uh I saw this pretty crazy
documentary that's been going on in the
at the Border in New Mexico and it is
there's a bunch of vigilante groups
because
um they come from these poor border
towns
they all look like Trevor's and
basically there's no law enforcement
there's like one sheriff for every like
50 miles right and then like so when
when a cartel crew comes through or
whatever
they're just helpless they don't know
what to do and then so they'll use the
resources of the Town they'll just start
like harassing members and then it's
like it literally looks like an old
school Western
it's like
I mean my first question would be like
where's the where's the federal
government helping yeah and then like
we're like how do we keep those towns
safe but a lot of the uh vigilante
groups were basically asking for help
from all these different
like States or whatever and then there's
volunteers that go but that's all they
have to do is like they have to be the
patrol
because the cocktail dudes would just
run in and like it's like a route for
them it is a thing I've seen a lot of
crazy [__] videos from this yeah like
like of ranchers who like live on the
border and like they're just dealing
with cartel members all the time like
it's it's a and like not just like some
migrant who's coming in like armed dudes
or like actually checking the property
out seeing if it's empty and trying to
like take it over for like a couple
nights damn that's crazy it's wild it's
wild yeah and those are the things that
I'm like wait don't we have a military
and like don't we have like yeah all
that stuff and I guess certain places
like the border is massive right yeah
California we got tons of [__] money
but like States like New Mexico and then
also like the Manpower we have like
millions of people versus like New
Mexico they don't they don't have [__]
as for like and most people live in like
the northern part right so it's like how
do you incentivize and then they don't
even have enough tax money in that town
to generate like so everyone just they
rely on volunteer police work
well bro like I got a neighbor right
he's from the UK he it took him forever
to get a [__]
um Green Card just so he could go home
and come back like he's married to a
[__] American so it's just one of
those things where it's like I think if
they cleaned up a lot of this nonsense
in the state department where it takes
forever for people to get approved yeah
like that would help a lot but instead
people got to do all kinds of desperate
means because they want to support their
families I can't blame anybody I would
do the same exact [__] yeah seriously
that's what I don't get is like
so people there's a lot of good honest
immigrants that just want to come work
that's all they want to do and most of
them don't want to stay they just want
to work send money back and then maybe
when they're country stable again
they'll go back like in most [__]
cases that's the story right and then
but there is a segment of like
extremists that would paint this picture
of migrants come here to [__] be on
welfare yeah pop out multiple kids and
then like just exploit American welfare
systems and I'm all like there might be
but it's pretty rare what I've seen
mostly is poor immigrants are coming
here they're the backbone of this the
country yeah five jobs they're the ones
yeah they're doing all the jobs that
once you become a citizen you don't want
yeah so I don't know man it's it's a
really tough thing to think it's a weird
topic yeah
there is a piece of companion
legislation that would make undocumented
entry into Texas a State Crime with
first-time offenders subject to a year
in prison two years in prison for second
time offenders and life in prison for
individuals with prior felony
convictions Democrats in Texas are
opposed to the bill likening the
legislation to a quote vigilante death
squad's policy
[Music]
seems like it's gonna end back seems
like some people who are trying to like
do some comic book [__] yeah because if
if I had a personal Vendetta and I hated
immigrants that's a perfect opportunity
for me to whoop something sign me up
yeah yeah that's like let me get on my
horse and [__] get my noose ready
like that's obviously people who feel
very strongly about this issue yeah and
who want to like make some change so I
don't know I just feel like it's a
slippery slope
it is it says quote this dangerous
radical and unconstitutional proposal
which empowers border Vigilantes to hunt
migrants and racially profile Latinos is
going to result in the death of innocent
people
um can we give it up though that they're
proposing it instead of just doing it
pretty cool that's pretty sick actually
if you think about Vigilantes I'm like
no they just do it who proposes it's
like Kick-Ass being like I'm not gonna
do [__] until I [__] get this pass by
the Senate oh my God yeah the superhero
bill just passed we're Phoenix Jones why
can't we have uh a more efficient system
like um for work program
you know exactly like also people from
countries that are that are actually
like like if they go back they're gonna
be murdered yep like what's Go I mean I
know it's not our problem but then
there's so much [__] land here
you know there's so much space people
are hiring all the time we have a crazy
shortage of just like just regular
[__] jobs like dude amnesty used to
be a real thing it used to be you know
people like they want to take that away
I guess or something
people like oh people game in the
amnesty system I'm like I think they
have a good argument yeah
I don't know I I just don't know enough
about the the way that the system works
to why it's [__] up the way it is and
in different states have different
policies right like because I get it
it's like why is it fair that a northern
state is making all these rules about
immigration when it's the southern
states that get hit with it yeah so that
that's like well if you guys are going
to sit in Washington and you don't have
to deal with the resource repercussions
of having an influx of millions of new
people then why don't you deal with it
and guess where they go though you think
they hang out in these board towns they
actually do go they go all over America
yeah all over and especially
metropolitan areas yeah that's what
happened with remember if you remember
the Ron DeSantis thing he's like oh
we're going to take all these you know
migrants who came to Florida they bust
yeah and bust them up to to Martha's
Vineyard yeah and it was a total like
obvious publicity stunt because you can
run for president and [__] but then like
in Martha's Journey they're like
yeah we don't want you here yeah we're
gonna bust you the [__] out of here even
though it was a stun it was a pretty
strong State that's what I thought when
I heard about it I was like that's a
stunt he's running for president I'm a
cynical person but then I was like that
was a strong statement because Martha's
Vineyard they're like get the [__] out
of here because they did say we don't
have anything to we can't help them we
love you oh my God we love you get the
[__] out they expose the hypocrisy yeah
they did Big Time the actual quote was
we don't have the resources to help any
of them but we got you a bus ticket to
get the [__] out and that's what sucks
right it's like it's this like virtue
signaling it's this like oh we gotta
help them but you guys are not here
though not here but you help them not me
you help them in your state yeah
I yeah
the Border towns aren't welcoming enough
that's why they're coming here but you
need to get the [__] out of here yeah
that was a really and you know what's
crazy it's such a ballsy move that they
did that because they knew nothing would
happen to them they knew that like they
could just kick them out again nothing
happened nobody came up their pissed
what was it on the news every night too
that they kicked them out like if Trump
did that [__] if he was like kicking
them out they would have been like yo
Trump's kicking all these people out
yeah exactly but since people in
Nantucket kicking them out and they're
like well they should do it yeah isn't
that wild right it's wild wow it's wild
that there was no repercussion for that
at all but on the on the flip side too
right like there are so many people that
do exploit the um the position system
yeah so like you have to check it and it
makes it's it's a brutal process because
like we know that there's marriage fraud
we know that there's sex trafficking we
know that all these things happen so
frequently we know in the 90 Day Fiance
is happening yeah so that so that uh
agents have to scrutinize and make sure
that they're letting they're not letting
in a psychopath they're not letting in a
fraudulent relationship or like whatever
it is right because
the more you do that I feel like you're
not qualifying the type of people to
come in for sure and you don't want
criminals and Psychopaths to come in you
want like hard-working good folks and
then have them be the majority of the
people that come in so how do you even
engage that though like I always wonder
what it's like to be the person that's
like you have to decide right now in
this span of minutes if this person's
allowed to stay or not that's why it's a
long process yeah like so like you know
green car problems
good point thank you but like think
about the whole like okay so like let's
say Refugee situations right so in
Refugee situations there's no time to
wait they're getting murdered at the
country so all the boat folks or
whatever uh they set up camps and then
people stay temporarily and then they
get screened and then after that they
get sponsored by different families and
I'm like why don't we do that anymore or
do we still do it I don't know
but how do you check on somebody if they
don't have any papers like how do you
find out who they were yeah do they yeah
they don't confirm like their the
database with like the Mexican database
or something is it kind of or if they
came all the way from like Honduras and
they like traveled all the way up and
they're just a bunch of Village folks no
papers they ran they got nothing on them
yeah like how do you is it just a mental
assessment at that point to like be like
oh we're gonna have a psych person look
after you and figure out if you're or
how do you even Merit based them it's
like hey uh
do something cool
that's what the refugee camp is it's
just a bunch of different odd jobs for
Chelsea who like falls into what
category right so [__] cool I don't
know how the screening process was but
my church oh I was not born during this
time but what my church did during
um that when a lot of Vietnamese and
Cambodian refugees came is um they
helped out with the work program stuff
so like they would teach uh the the
different refugees that would come a
skill or a trade that they wanted to
learn like auto mechanic or restaurant
or whatever right and then so people at
the church who had businesses would uh
train them in a in a skill yeah that's
cool yeah
[Music]
laughs